[Music]
the gifts keep on coming for the cast of
Will & Grace
especially for Debra Messing Michelle
Turner was there as Debra received her
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
we love you I'll speak for everyone
besties Marishka Hargitay in tears
introducing an emotional message my
dream long ago so I'm overwhelmed humble
and very emotional Debra's 13 year old
son Roman diving in for hugs before
posing with his mom who glowed in gold
Oscar de la Renta and of course Debra's
Will & Grace co-stars Eric McCormack and
Megan Mullaly were there Sean Hayes was
homesick her buddies Connie Britton and
Sophia Bush were also by her side did
you ever dream this no never never
my big dream was to be a working actress
finally we're coming out and that's very
exciting
we were with Messing on the set of her
very first sitcom Ned and Stacey back in
1996 I have a man two years later she
was starring in Will & Grace
Deborah telling us nearly 20 years later
she's still hopeful for Grace's romantic
future Harry Connick jr. is coming back
next week yes we can you tell me he's so
good it's so good
can there be a happy ending who knows
you